you thank you good morning I also like
to thank the organizers for inviting me
to this very interesting workshop and
for giving me the opportunity to present
some of my work so I work on comunitario
models simple but still hopefully
meaningful cognate oreal models for
problems in the computational biology
and today I will in particular talk
about models for computing network
modules so in network biology the goal
is to understand the physical and
functional architecture of the cell in
terms of app swagg network models and
then of course to explore this knowledge
in terms of finding new drug targets
improving methods for classification etc
and this is a very ambitious goal as we
all know the cell is very complex but
luckily the cell is organized in terms
of modules so these are sort of more or
less well-defined functional building
blocks that help the carry of the cell
carry out its function and therefore
it's a meaningful task at the network
level also to look for these Network
modules and in this talk I will consider
a module as a connected sub Network in
some larger biological interaction
network and I will present models and
algorithms for finding these modules in
two scenarios basically one if there's
only network data available and the
other one if there's network data and
additional data we can use to find
basically active regions giving that
data in the network and I assume in this
talk that this data is given in the form
of p-values which is often the case in
biological experiments so the talk is
roughly structured along this schema so
this axis here denotes the number of
networks so we can have one network and
do something or we can have two or more
networks and then on top of this axis
these are network only approach to
Center below this is the when you have
additional data at hand so if you only
have one network and nothing else then
you can still look for modules in terms
of topological structures within this
network for example clustering the
network looking for complexes they've
also done some work here on class the
editing a nice model but I don't have
the time to speak about this today if
you have two or more networks then you
can identify modules by comparing
similar structures between these two
networks may be from different species
of strains and you can do this by
Network alignment in this way you can
find conserved modules and I will
present my work on this part shortly
after this if you do have additional
data then you can look for active
modules given that data and you can
combine this if you have additional data
and multiple networks you can you look
for conserved active modules very likely
I will not have the time to go into our
work on this topic so the first part is
a simple model for conserved modules so
our work on global pairwise network
alignment and so this is somewhat older
work it started in 2008-2009 then with
the help of my former PhD student
mohamed el kebir we approved this in the
last year's so here's the model so i
focus on pairwise restricted global
network alignment so I call this
restricted or sparse and that's really
the key word here in this title what do
I mean this means that forgiving note in
one network I'm only allowed to map it
to a subset of other nodes in the other
network and this is a big restriction of
course but it makes often send so many
times we have given these relations in
terms of ethology databases so we know
something about the nodes we want to map
to and I'm sorry in this case we can we
can exploit this and in this case this
model will work if we allow a note to go
to any other node in the network of this
model is not good okay but what is it
actually so the input is 2 networks
g1 and g2 and I have to slowing
functions 1c for mapping notes on to
each other and 1w for mapping pairs of
nodes on to each other so this is a very
common scoring function in edward
alignment then i can define an alignment
network alignment as a partial injective
function a that goes from the first
graph to the other graph the node sets
with a scorer s which is basically the
some of the notes that are note scores
that I map to each other plus the sum of
the node pairs that are mapped to each
other so as i said i look at the
restricted k so in this case this this
value ciak sorry where is it here so
this will be minus infinity for most of
the node pairs and then we have been
restricted instance yes please
in this definition this is arbitrary but
what I'm going to use later is indeed if
this function W will have will be for
example 1 if I have an edge between a
pair of nodes here and an edge between a
pair of nodes here but you can use it
for that case but it is more general
okay and then of course the goal it's
the communitarian optimization problem
is to find the best alignment one less
alignment in this scenario okay so how
do we do this well if you look at this
problem then you may be realize that
this is close to something which is very
well studied for for many many years a
very nice problem which is called
quadratic assignment and this is a
facility location problem so in
quadratic assignment the input is a set
of facilities and a set of locations and
we have a flow between the facilities so
this is given in this matrix does not
have to be symmetric for example we have
1.5 things going from green facility to
read and from red to green we have 1.3
and so forth and then we have a distance
matrix so we want to place the
facilities in some locations in various
distances between these locations so
what's the problem now well the problem
is to find a bijection so we really have
to place each facility somewhere such as
to minimize the scoring function if this
scoring function again has pairwise
terms so if I look at a pair and so
basically is the sum of the products of
distances times the flows of the
facilities decide to these distances so
in essence you want to put facilities
that have exchanged a lot of flow close
to each other so here's a little example
for the scoring function if I just look
at this pair the green and the red
facility they are placed on the yellow
and the blue spot so the distance
between the yellow and the blue spot is
1.2 okay and the flow I exchanged
between red and green is 1.5 and green
and red is 1.3 so I sum this up
and this is these are two of these terms
in this objective function the overall
aim is to minimize to find an assignment
that minimizes this function and so the
nice thing about this program is that it
is well studied of course it is hard
it's a hard problem it's also hard to
approximate but there's a nice model for
it a nice integer programming model and
this goes back to Jean Lola who was a
professor here at Berkeley and also one
of the founding fathers of the field of
combinatorial optimization and you can
see this is from 63 so this formulation
has been around for a while but it's
still very useful so how does it work
well we have an integer variable X ok
it's a binary variable it is one if we
place facility I on location k ok and
then the objective function just models
the the objective function from
quadratic assignment if we put I to K
and J 2 L then we can't this term WI kjl
which is defined just as the product of
the flow times the distance ok and then
the constraints are such that we have a
by jective function and assignment and
so this is a nice model of course it's
still a quadratic model so we have to do
something is not going to be so easy to
solve this but at this level it's very
nice to see that this is very related to
network alignment because I can put a
network alignment model here which is
very heavily inspired from this so it's
almost the same but not quite so we have
some differences which are highlighted
in red here so first of all we don't
minimize we maximize but this is not a
real difference so it's just the same
basically then we have an additional
linear term and the objective function
again this is not this is not a problem
then our matrix is symmetric in network
alignment which is just nice we can
forget about half the variables but it's
again not dramatic then we don't have an
assignment we have a matching so we have
impartial injective function so we just
have less than or equals here instead of
equalities
but that's the major difference but the
big butt excuse me the big difference is
really hidden and this is a well my W
matrix is sparse because i use the
restricted input and only then will it
work nicely this model so the quadratic
assignment problem is considered a very
hard problem even for heart problems
it's one of one of the hard ones so
instances with 30 facilities or so are
considered hard to solve whereas I claim
where I will show that I can solve this
for in the restricted case for a large
for large networks so it just works
nicely and the reason is that i really
only look at a subset of nodes that can
map 1 no 2 so this is essential here
okay so how do we solve it again we
build upon nice work of other people
there is Alomar's and relaxation
approach for the quadratic assignment
problem which is due to adams and
Johnson from the Year 94 and the way it
works is well you have this product of
binary variables you can linearize it so
you introduce new variables Y and this
models the product and then you split
this variable in two copies so this
technique is called variable splitting
so you have two copies of Y and you add
an inequality and you enforce that these
copies have to be the same then you can
take this in quality equality and relax
it so you do lies it put it to the
objective function and penalize the
violation with the Lagrangian term and
then you apply the quanzhen relaxation
by iterating and solving these relax
problems and the relaxed problem is in
both cases so this works on the left
this works on the right this is here
it's just assignment problems a bunch of
assignment problems you have to solve
here it's a bunch of bipartite matching
problems you have to solve but so this
way you can solve these problems so we
implemented this a while ago and at the
time in our first paper I compared it to
the state of the art and our method
which is called Natalie did very well
and and recently I wanted to update this
so I took one more recent alignment tool
which is el growl
and this again last year was published
last year has been shown to perform well
against the within the state of the art
so now compared the our method against
elegua and I took six networks from
string and I did all against all
comparisons of these are fairly large
networks and here are the results so you
can see so these are the comparisons on
this axis so these are warm fly rat
mouse and human networks and so we
compared to things so one is the
symmetric substructure score which is
two recently introduced nice way to
evaluate the quality of alignment so
it's one if they're both aligned
perfectly I don't go into the details
here and here you can see that not only
does better than al igual especially on
the large networks and also the other
measure is the largest connected shared
component which is basically the size of
the alignment so here you can see that
the methods are roughly the same one
nice thing I noticed when running these
experiments is that so these networks
are really large so ye said 150,000
edges or so and many many thousands of
nodes but still you can see with laganja
relaxation you get up on lower bounds as
you optimize and of course you hope that
these converge and here this work very
well so we get almost perfect
convergence so we can show that all
these instances can be solved within one
or two percent optimal and I should tell
you maybe what the scoring function is
used indeed I did the optimize the edge
conservation which is just my W matrix
will ever one if I have an edge in one
network and match and the other network
of them I maximize the number of shared
edges and this work very well in this
case okay so the next topic I want to
speak about this is now if you do have
additional data at hand and this is a
simple model for active models modules
sorry and this is joint work with people
from verts book we started this also a
while ago and tooth
seven and well how does it work so if we
have additionally measurements on the
cell which tell us something about
what's going on in the cell like for
example differential differential
expression data or D was a proteomics
data media genomics data and in this
case a here I assume this comes in the
form of p-values then of course you can
look at the data you can order the
p-values and you can devise hypothesis
but you can also look at the data in the
context of the network of an interaction
network protein interaction network or
other networks and this and then you can
look for active regions given that data
in the network this idea so the first
paper I know is a paper right way I
Dakar and colleagues from 2002 so
roughly defined an active module is a
subset of connected a well a subset of
genes that induce a connected sub
network in the network and shows strong
signal in the data and this last part
it's a matter of how you want to model
this so basically you want your active
module to have lower p values than
expected by chance but there's different
ways of modeling this and our way is as
follows so here we follow an approach by
pounds and morris in 2003 so you can
look at the density histogram of the p
value so it's a data-driven approach and
you can model this so here's here's the
distribution from some real data set you
can model this as a mixture of a signal
and the noise component and you can say
that signal for us a beater distribution
the noise is uniformly distribution and
then the by this you can fit the
parameters to this beta uniform mixture
model and you can derive a nice log
likelihood ratio score for the activity
of one node which is just the logarithm
of the signal over the noise and what's
even nicer in this model from pounds and
morris you can work in the FDR so give
him the false discovery rate this
translates into a threshold p-value tau
such that genes or nodes with lower p
value will have a positive score
and at how you get a score of 0and genes
this Portnoy's genes will get a negative
score so if you now sum up this course
of jeans or nodes of a module we get a
score of a module and under the
assumption that the p-values are
independent this is lock likelihood
ratio score for a whole module and then
it makes sense to look for the maximum
likelihood module which converts to
finding a sub set of nodes that induce
connected sub graph and maximize this
function which is just the sum of these
things and it's a linear function so the
problem we look at here is again a nice
combinatorial optimization problem this
is called maximum weight connected
subgraph and it's as follows so input is
a graph and these activity function
which tells you something about the
activity of the nodes then just find
what I just described a subset of nodes
that it uses a connected sub graph and
such that the scores maximum and again
there's a very similar problem around
which has been studied oops wrong p
sorry which has been studied intensively
and this is the price collecting
signatory program so if you look at this
it's almost the same so given a graph
now we have no profits and edge costs
the tasks will find is connected sub
graph but now the score is the sum of
the node profits minus the sum of the
edge costs and well it's easy to see or
we could show that these problems are
basically the same so if you can do one
you can do the other their equivalent
you inherit of course also the bad
things of course this problem is hard
it's also hard to approximate but you
can use algorithms for price collecting
Steiner tree to solve this model which
is what we did in our first version so
recently we have implemented a new
version of our algorithm which is a
dedicated eigen for this problem so it's
based on heavy pre-processing then we
look at the graph you make a
decomposition of this graph into its
by connected components and try
connected components and we recursively
work our way up the hard part sweet self
them still within I LP formulation and
it's also nice to see that this model so
looking for modules as price collecting
standard freeze has been picked up by
other people so at this workshop we have
seen in the first day the talk by Ernest
Franco where they do this also Fabio
presented his model where he does this
and he showed some very impressive
running times and well this was a sort
of simple scoring function but here we
have a little bit more complicated
scoring function but again we see the
similar things so if an instance takes
five minutes or so to solve to
optimality then we consider this a heart
instance so we can really solve large
instances of this problem to optimality
and we applied this to a large number of
studies a large number of omics data and
I want to report about one such
application which is a collaboration
with the lab of matina Smith at the food
& amsterdam and it's about human
cytomegalovirus HD MV which is a herpes
virus it's very common so the majority
of people is infected but usually it's
it's harmless unless the immune system
is compromised and then it can be linked
to many diseases retinitis hepatitis and
also some cancers and the way the virus
works is it expresses for g
protein-coupled receptor proteins and
replaces the host proteins and by that
it's able to hijack basically the
signaling pathways of the cell so in
this study this was about one of these
receptors he was 28 and there was a
mouse cell lines one expressing use 28
and one control cell line and the data
was differential expression so for use
28 it is known that this is somehow
involved in the beta catenin signaling
pathway and mediates be too convenient
signaling but it's not clear how so it
was clear that this does not go via the
canonical wind pathway but well if not
this then how else and this was exactly
what this experiment was about to find
out how this could go so we complimented
this traditional gene expression study
by oops again by a network approach so
we applied our model we use as network
we use the CAC signaling signaling and
metabolic Mouse network and we computed
an active module and I will show you the
results inside escape if it works yes
nice so here we see the background a
large interaction network here we see
the module you can really read it these
are the genes with their names you can
see the fold change coded in color so
this is already nice but our
collaborators also wanted to see this
module in the context of enriched
categories geo can't agrees kak pathways
so we implemented a cytoscape plugin a
nap this is called examine this was
together with researchers and
visualization from eindhoven and here
you get a different view of the module
so again you see visualization of the
module but you also see the enriched
category so it shows function and
pathway here and this allowed our
collaborators to for example pathways
and cancer certainly interesting so this
phosphate signaling pathways interesting
then they saw that this pathway in
cancer basically can be divided into two
functions growth factor activity and of
course beta-catenin binding which they
were interested in so this way you can
explore this module and they could
basically identify this access here
which they are previously overlooked
this matt hcf mad axis so I can I can
maybe highlight it okay they focused
focused on this axis and studied little
bit more and were able then based on
this to formulate a new hypothesis which
is basically so this is the same you
that where's this axis here hgf met that
us 28 upregulates HTF this leads to the
activation of this hgf mad axis and wire
met then beta-catenin is released into
the cell and nicely they made
experiments by
this module and they could validate the
first part that you see indeed elevated
h GF levels in u.s. 28 used cells in the
lab and so currently we're waiting for
for new data follow-up experiments and
to compute new models for Martinez myth
okay well so I showed you some simple
models for some simply combinatorial
problems and so the first talk of this
workshop so try IDK show this picture
and we have seen many many successful
methods that that follow this approach
basically so integration of many many
many many many different data sources
and then using a sophisticated modern
machine learning techniques to interpret
the output in finding many biologically
relevant without so why is there than
still room for these simple methods and
simple models are presented well I think
they're this still makes a lot of sense
because in a simple model you're really
close to the entities so you can really
still simple models that simple so you
can understand what's going on right
also by definition simple models only
have few parameters and you know that
with many parameters you can basically
fit a lot of things so this is also
beneficial and finally the simple models
I showed so I could use the relation to
some well study problems and basically I
see it also as this so if there's only a
handful of hard combinatorial problems
and some are easy to solve and and if
you can identify what makes the problem
hard and how he can build a larger
problem based on these components this
can be very powerful and this is also
why this can play a big role here
because signal models make it then
possible in some cases to device exact
algorithms if you have an exact
algorithm you have provably optimal
solutions especially if you combine many
many many different models and you make
errors by heuristic
optimization so this will propagate in
various ways and you don't know anymore
what what you get so therefore it's nice
to have simple models as building blocks
and to solve them exactly so this
concludes my talk I want to thank my
contributors both in method development
but also for the application studies in
particular I want to thank Marcos
division 2 b.s Miller from birdsburg
whom i started the active modules
project with and we still collaborate
and it's a lot of fun I also want to
thank my former PhD student mohammed el
Kebir who contributed a lot to the
topics are presented today I want to
thank Brown University and Ben reference
group for hosting me currently i'm doing
a sabbatical there and i want to thank a
fulbright program for partial support
and what here is the tools we
implemented they're all open source I
hope you will use some of them and thank
you for your attention
q okay very good alignment quality
compared to how to be compared means of
functional an equality and also do the
running time okay very good questions
yes so I didn't know it was as cute but
now I know that's how i always say s3
thanks so as cube so functional
evaluation is a bit difficult i would
say because what you can do you can you
can you can look at the go terms for
example you find and what we found at
least at the time is that all these
methods if you follow the scoring
function they have a way to put the
sequence contribution in and so then you
have some alpha time sequence and 1
minus alpha times topology and we always
found that if we do sequence only we get
the best we get the best functional
scores just because these databases also
build that way so but we did these
comparisons and we compare it also
especially in this case I think for the
for the larger networks where we had so
better as so much better as cube we also
had much better functional scores
morning time yes in this case I limited
the running time to 10 minutes CPU time
for both methods and as I said for for
my method this was enough to to converge
and I also the other method i think
didn't change the results when i let it
one also for one hour and it didn't
change
the modules solution is there's a way
you can do this you can adapt the
integer linear program and find the best
k modules so I also implemented this for
the expression data we looked at it's
mostly that for the interesting fdr's
you find one module and then of course
if you if you if you decrease the FDR
this will break down into multiple
pieces but this is the way we look at
the modules we do you usually then don't
find so the next best module would be a
singleton or something so this is not so
interesting but there's a way to to also
compute multiple modules I mean the most
easy way is just compute the best one
take it out and do it again but there's
also otherwise we camp you can compute
the best k at the same time but it in
the real data this wasn't really
appropriate for some reason there was
only one always one dominating module
for expression data
you follow up actually so the
formulation depends a lot on the
parameter right I mean essentially as
you move the parameter some of the
scores of the nodes are becoming again
yes so in that sense wouldn't it make
sense to actually look a different
videos of that parameter and then study
the modules some different videos over
anyway it's a very good command so
that's it actually what we do if we won
the method on some real data we start
with a very loose FDR so you see a very
big module and the way it works with the
FDR this is as you said it's just it
just if you if you decrease the FDR all
the scores get more negative but this is
sort of a linear offsets you really zoom
into if you lower the FDR you zoom into
the interesting regions of of the module
and therefore it's really just a zooming
in there for aggregating is also not so
interesting because it's it's almost
always just subset relations so you can
but that's what we do we bury this
parameter restart relaxed and then we
zoom in to some interesting sighs
analytically did it TV you for the
module
this scoring function nope so we because
it's networks in there so this is very
difficult I think I can't I mean it's
very interesting question but we do of
course is we get empirical p values by
running on randomized networks and then
complaining the results but analytically
I can't
alright let's take the speaker again